hi Samuel leaves here I'm with my
beautiful wife hi I'm Amanda Leeds
Amanda leaves and we're in Wolverhampton
centre sorts the property for Lee Lee
Lawrence who's a top top guy and this is
a video for Lee but also other people
can watch as well so a sea level around
it's the first time I've seen it since
Lee bought it
and he bought it for 82 thousand pounds
which is a pretty of a steal because
you're doing it's right in central
Wolverhampton and four bedrooms you
throw nourished it I'm about to you're
bout to furnish it so Amanda's about to
furnish you to make you look lovely but
first let's look at it and see if the
bait is okay fingers crossed it will
look good
oh let's have a look okay smells nice
smells very new you can show some a
member okay so I'm seeing this is
bedroom one let's see Wow
[Music]
really nice feature will make the
difference hamsa base
a lot of this trip considering that we
bought a hundred houses last year it is
gorgeous
okay first bedroom on this let me get
them against communal area yes yeah
[Music]
I liked it yeah
[Music]
Wow this is that like a life sell
something Oh ours the thermostat is like
fancy Thanks oh right oh wow really nice
okay now time to look at the kitchen a
bathroom
possibly the two most important rooms
love great title they're nice
yeah so modern
oh my gosh this is so nice
ah it's just gorgeous can't believe how
well it's been done oh it gets better
nice place that you have in your own
home the video does not do it justice
this looks amazing
oh really is just brilliant Lee you
should be a happy boy I'm exactly how
much you paid for the refurb but they've
done a great job great sure look at the
rooms yeah yeah
[Music]
get the light on swing these files and
really good fighters rather very solid
heavy doors I think the lights will have
a top okay go for it so what's a sense
oh oh - Masha very nice they've gone to
town on this they really have Wow
so you can't leave a light on because
they were all automatic that's really
cool by the way for the record
Amanda acts like this every time we go
into a new house so they all look nice I
know she seems surprised but this is how
Amanda Waller thing about you just love
Houston now look at the view the view is
not very good but does it matter will it
affect the rent and the answer is a big
fat no no a big fat northern oh so big -
bedroom so far
did you throw I do really like it I
think Lee's done very well here what
we're gonna work great house I'm telling
them well I didn't buy this house I mean
geez
yeah good check out the window great
view Namie open it ah I think so nice
forest a windows yeah but that's good
because it saves people dying yes
again with the view we can see a car
wash
I would not want to particularly wake up
to but the question will affect the rent
no no ok next room last no room for this
room is killer I never expected that I
mean what how big is this room this this
is like for the smallest room because if
this is the third room usually the
smallest room is a box room but we only
saw houses where we have four good-sized
rooms and secondly Amanda I want you to
tell us what the five checklists are the
five things that make a good hmm
interest in this house has it okay so
and go so the five points and on the
checklist or a good Pedro
for Less ballrooms and all the rooms
into me how big so a square foot which
this has best men this is the smallest
room and it's all open this is about a
hundred and twenty yeah this is like
really good-sized got that Nance the
center we like a stone throw away from
poor captaincy Center so faithless also
needs and to be in good condition which
this one I don't know what the times
look like when he bought it but he
wouldn't have been terrible with it
although he's done a like refurb I
imagine this house probably had about
any 7,000 pounds pending yep yep and
then in terms of cost wise for the house
30 random room is what you we would joke
and this one has a lot less for 30 grand
of room is 124 a for bed HMO but he
bought this about five months ago and
how prices are shooting up so we say
thirty grand the roof we used to say 25
grand a room in a few months time we'll
say 35 grand a group so what I would say
is if you're watching this in this 2017
and you need to buy right now before
prices continue to rise lastly you need
a good hater manager nearby of which I
think Lee and Jane actually met le quick
move and she dropped off this Tuesday at
our offices so yeah thanks
high five so congratulations lead for
buying a house for eighty two thousand
pounds which will have tenants in very
soon paying fourteen hundred pounds per
month what a killer return and
congratulations so congratulations Lee
if you if you want to pop by to the up
for some time we'll bring some wine and
celebrate have a great day
[Music]